- It's nice to have new
coaches on "The Voice,"
and y'all are so good, you and Chance.
I do love In that clip, that
Chance thought it was so funny
that you were turning Blake's chair around
as you turned his around.
- Yeah, Just like, "What's going on?"
(laughs)
- [Kelly Clarkson] That was awesome!
- Then I just head-butted yours.
- I love too, though,
that you jumped right in
to giving Shelton crap. I love it!
- No, for sure, I love winding him up.
- Cause you're a country boy.
Like, we're country people too.
And so it was, like, really nice
that you came in and, like,
just felt right at home with that.
- Wind the old man up!
- Made me feel really good.
(laughs)
- I was like, I have a team.
- You're a pro at it.
- I am. I am. Well,
practice makes perfect.
(laughs)
- So, you've definitely perfected, though,
the Blake impression.
We've done interviews for the show and he,
I want you to just, how
do you talk like Blake?
- Well, the other day they told me
I sounded like Forrest Gump.
- No, you don't!
(laughs)
- He was saying that. He's Dumb.
- This is my last season on "The Voice."
(laughs)
- I want you to be on my team,
and I hate Kelly Clarkson.
(laughs)
- Yep.
- [Niall Horan] That's what
it usually sounds like.
- About sums it up.
(laughs)